kick some ass get the girl and try to
look dope got you do it your knee drop
three seconds to comply what
three two one in the dark you could have
just asked me
the device that controls every military
satellite in the world
just falling into the hands of four very
dangerous guys we need someone who can
move like them fight like them it's time
to be patriot there are no more Patriots
just rebel and tyrants so which are you
I'm xxx I'll introduce you to your
ground team alright it comes Red Bulls
poster self I'm not gonna have crowns
watch my back who would you trust a good
the extreme friendly completely insane
Oh which one I got what you need now
that's the team I can work with here we
go
it's refreshing you actually know what
you're doing down there
yeah that's what she says Wow these case
of yours are the real kind of trouble
you have no idea what you're up against
whatever it is you're looking for you're
gonna come up short this is me you're
not making me breakfast in the morning
we're willing to die you keep the world
safe how about you I live for this I
guess we're on the same team now you
ready to have some fun I go look
let me simplify flee kick some ass get
the girl and try to look dope why are
you doing
dan it feels good to be back
[Music]